with fiction we create our own heroes
and villains
as role play for the soul so no one
really gets hurt but when you go through
those things
your body doesn't know it's not real
when you cry a fiction you're crying
yeah you're really crying i think you
make me cry worse though because
you've brought me so many laughs that
i'm more emotionally connected to you as
a friend
so when you get upset i it really gets
me going there is a generation of people
now where you can look at them in the
eye they'll do one
brent quote and you instantly go i like
once you understand the motivation of
brent that
he's he wants to be popular and there's
a camera there so that's going to catch
him being a [__] as well
once you understand that everything
makes sense it's this
this quest to be popular it's never a
good thing in know
if you're famous from the age of 15 or
want to be famous for 15 or 20 it sort
of defines you because that's the world
you live in you think everything
everyone acts like that you pick up the
symptoms you're worried about going out
you're worried about being packed you're
worried about your hair it's madness
it's a game it doesn't mean anything my
job is to let people know it doesn't
matter
we're all [__] idiots and that's
great i wanted to be a pop star and i
should have wanted to be a musician and
then when i came to this
i knew i wanted to own my own labour and
create the work i wanted to be the
writer director
the acting was whatever being on the red
carpet whatever
my fat face on the screen whatever to
lead the orchestra you've got to turn
your back on the audience
and that just sums up i i think ah
it's not a democracy what's your
motivation at this point then because
like you've
you've done everything you've made lots
of money like why aren't you just
chilling out in a beach somewhere it's
still
fun for me it's i get up every day and i
do what i want
i mean that's that's rare
we're about to interview ricky gervais
lawrence
made it oh are the cameras on might as
well just start
switch them all on now everything on all
everything's wrong
everything's on we'll set you over there
ricky
appreciate it yeah it is a bit
she did do a lot of tests on this table
last week we've been watching a lot of
scanning dramas about serial killers
yeah it was a setup like this
well we saw you we thought was best yeah
normally on podcasts
yeah technically we're normally uh
we normally spend a couple hours we've
had quite a few big names
we we sort of try and uh slip in as many
office references as we can but we can't
really get away with it you're all right
i'm sponsored by volvik
so let's get that straight away they
love you fantastic
crap they'll be sponsored by water oh
yeah no offense
we do actually have a youtube friend who
had a buxton water sponsorship for a
little while as much free water
which is none at all mum i've sorted
this for life
yeah this is the only occasion i drink
water um
through the night yeah hung over i've
got a big drought following
pissing it down the sink love it again
look at that amount of water
amazing yeah we got the links yesterday
for afterlife
all right appreciate that we watched it
through had a bit of a chat today
enjoyed it
are you excited about it coming out yeah
yeah i can't wait
what was the sort of the goal behind it
then well
um i suppose i don't know if it's
because you get older or because
you want to keep pushing the envelope
but uh
it's more dramatic and it's more
philosophical
and it's darker it's [__] dark like
it is it's very [__]
because i've lost someone before and he
was very close to me and i was like whoa
this is like bringing me back to
just being like what's the point do you
know what i mean i mean it is about it
is about grief
and um and it's not it's not like it's
rare it's not like people sitting around
guys
what's grief and then nothing's ever
happened to me ever
so everyone asso everyone goes through
grief you know the first thing you go
through
i remember i remember grief at five when
my cat died
you know what i mean i thought this i'm
never gonna go over this yeah you're
never gonna get actually yeah um
and uh so yeah basically it hits the
ground running
you see me watching a um
a laptop and it's my wife and she's
clearly going through
chemotherapy and she's making a video
diary and she says if you're watching
this i'm not around anymore
so you know straight away he's lost his
wife and you find out that was the love
of his life
he's in depression or he's angry um
and uh you know you find out that he was
gonna commit suicide
straight away but the dog was hungry um
which is sort of funny but also real
yeah i think people do think well i've
got to feed that offer
if you're going to you think i've got to
feed the dog first yeah you just would
people fold their clothes when they walk
into the sea or
you know so um and it gives him
long enough to think right okay okay i'm
gonna
carry on for as long as i can but i'm
gonna punish the world
i'm gonna do and say whatever the [__] i
want from now on um
and that's where they started with that
sort of high concept you changed the
rules basically
like you did that in the invention of
lions exactly and you really change the
rules and you become like i'm living by
my own rules
yeah yeah and then and he thinks that
this is amazing because
even though i'm in pain and i'm and i
hate it and i can't wait to be with her
dead um i'm gonna have a blast because
nothing can hurt me now i'm not scared
of anything anymore you know when he
gets mugged he's not scared
because usually you think i i could
fight back but i've got a baby in a
stroller
they know where i live he thinks
couldn't give her so
it's like he thinks it's like a
superpower um but that's why i quite
enjoyed about that was actually because
someone who actually wants to commit
suicide actually maybe wouldn't really
think like that so it sort of shows his
kind of
i'm not saying it's not realistic it's
sort of the level of arrogance or sort
of the human ego that
keeps you going i want to kill myself
and so many people say that but how many
of them would actually do it to go
through with it in that well
i mean it it i'm creating a fiction so
uh uh i i i everyone feels differently
about this
yeah and uh and i have i should say i
haven't suffered from depression or
suicidal thoughts that
i've been lucky because it is it's you
know um
uh some people suffer those things and
they haven't gone through anything it's
just it's it's a
you know an illness um but i've created
this fiction
to to explore it and he goes in and out
you know and i think people walking
around
they seem funny to you but they go home
and they could think about it every day
for all we know
and that comes out as well treating
people you don't know what they're going
through
you don't know what is um his
brother-in-law
yeah and he's he's too busy in his own
grief because
his brother is also having a bad time in
his marriage and that's another theme
that everyone thinks what they're going
through is worse than anyone else i've
had it on twitter
um i did a joke about um peanut
allergies and i talk about it in
humanity
where someone says um i should never
joke about food allergies i say hold on
i talk about aids cancer famine and the
holocaust
yeah and you're telling me i shouldn't
joke about food allergies she sent back
yes but the holocaust didn't kill
children
so she's like this is my thing it's the
worst it's the worst thing and
everything's their thing is the worst he
thinks
he's and i make him meet people that are
worse off than him
and he still thinks you know and you
know sometimes he feels a bit spoiled
and
so um there's lots of flavors in it
because there's lots of flavors in the
world he meets people he wouldn't have
met when he was happily married and home
with his wife every
you know he sort of goes into sort of
the underbelly of society almost and
finds out that
they're people too yeah you know and uh
uh
so it is like an adventure it's like he
thinks it's one last adventure
like it felt like he's looking at like a
computer game a little bit like oh well
if it's game over at the end that's
that's fine
he is exactly that's exactly right you
think you can
if you really don't worry about the
consequences you you can do
anything who cares but then of course
what he's trying to do is he's trying to
make himself into a psychopath so he
doesn't feel anything anymore and you
can't do that
because you're burdened with conscience
and
and we've if you look back on it once
you've watched it all you realize that
actually
he was nice to vulnerable people just
instinctively he cared about his dog
he cared about the new girl he cared
about the old lady he cared about his
nephew
so he tried to pick on people his own
size so to speak
intuitively because he's basically a
nice bloke and you can't
you can't pretend to be a psychopath so
there you go you don't need to watch it
anymore we've explained the whole thing
this probably sounds like people are
going what am i gonna watch that yeah
it's funny
it is funny constantly it's very dark
it'll be funny but it's funny in the
dark
like i think a lot of your jokes in the
past have come out of dark scenarios
like obviously of course
on stage especially doing your comedy
this is this is the darkest thing you've
done isn't it i think it's the darkest
thing i've done because it's it's sort
of i
it feels more like drama with laughs
yeah and that is because
i've spent the last two or three i
haven't watched i just haven't watched
um
terrestrial tv for two or three years
and nothing in english
yeah nothing in english everything the
last three years i've watched ever
since the bridge and the killing i've
just found
every foreign drama usually to do with
a serial killing or something but um and
the pacing's different yeah very much it
felt very modern pacing
to me there was like elements of like um
i don't know what you've watched but
like there was it was a little bit
curved at times
that that pacing that element
yeah and a lot of people watch it and go
this is just [__] normal guys day why
am i watching this so it's
so slow it felt a little bit like
atlanta times like just normal things
happening tonight i haven't seen that
but i've heard about it it's really good
it was like it is it is normal things
happen to normal people
it's just that um uh that the normal
person is going through something
um and uh and and people said about
derrick they said this it's a comedy or
drama i said well it's a fake
documentary so what's your real life
it's for everything you know we want we
want it to be a comedy but then we find
a lump
you know it's like all the time
in there it's up and down isn't it what
we're thinking i think this is more
towards drama than the
previous things of being a bit more
towards the pendulum swung a little bit
further isn't it
i think it is yeah i think it is exactly
the way you're feeling about well it's
also
i think it's also because um uh
it's a more of a serial you can watch
this in one go because of the nature of
netflix and binge watching
it's one story it's like a two and a
half hour story
it's like a it's like the serialization
of a novel
without actually going through all the
pain of actually writing the novel
brilliant
okay yeah you did get to the end of each
episode and think oh i do want to watch
the next one like there wasn't a point
where you sort of thought i
could leave it there or something
something happens every time you want to
see
there's a new development so um yeah
again i i um i think that just sort of
happens when you structure something
that's got a lot of flavors
you have to stick to the plot a little
bit and that's what drives it it's still
the plot you want to know what happens
to him
there are moments where you i i cried i
said to you i cried
it was the start but for me though he's
done
he's sort of losing the plot on that
it's always parents were you
invention a lion like old people yeah
derrick the same that's when i cry
yeah of course of course we're gonna
once they're gone they're they're gone
forever
and you know did did i did i treat them
did they know
did they know how much i loved them and
all those things
we with fiction we create our own heroes
and villains
as role play for the soul so no one
really gets hurt
but when you go through those things
your body doesn't know it's not real
so when you cry a fiction you're crying
yeah you're really crying
you know a lot of this uh what we're
talking earlier because we're
huge fans of you basically thank you
regret is something that's
in a lot of the the moments that you
create those emotions from you always
seem to go back to regret
because um i'm all for forgiveness
i i hate the idea of someone's not
forgiven you know i think
this life is so short but to carry
things to the grave
it's just it's tragedy and an old person
looking back
the song that kills me is willie nelson
singing
always on my mind it [__] it destroys
me
this for oh my god you want to go it's
all right mate you know so i'm
i'm yeah i do i do look at i look at the
big themes and did try and deconstruct
them and make them fun or interesting or
or tragic i want i want people to um
i want people to feel anything really it
feels very classic
um you if i say classic javascript weird
sounds very classic you themes
in this yeah so if you are a ricky
gervais fan because philosophy your
philosophies are
in this house yeah but yeah like to me
you're becoming a bit like the eminem of
com
comedy in the sense that you're being
known for this thing
and as you're getting older and you're
developing and you're going off in
different directions
the people i don't when i was watching
this i was thinking oh how are people
going to take this because i know
derek was different and some people i
loved it but some people
criticize it and this is of course a
step even further again
are you thinking about or how is this
going to be never putting it out
never forget thinking about that you you
do it you do it for yourself
that way at least you come up with
something interesting and different
i mean if you start second guessing
people you'll end up pleasing no one
so i said in everything i do it should
be uh uncompromised
you know um uh we've got enough safe
anodyne
drama comedy everything most things
in every genre are [__] they are
yeah most tables are [__] most artists
[__] most music is [__]
most everything most youtubers [__] as
well actually
we're the exceptions so you want to try
and get in that top
few percent that isn't [__] right and
you're going to lose
a big chunk but who cares and it's the
same with
with anything you know it's this this
this quest to be popular
it's never a good thing in art it's
never a good thing if it happens
great right but if you aim it you'll
come unstuck and
i i i always say this the bigger you
become the more famous you become the
more successful you become the more
eminent whatever the more people love
you
and the more people hate you because
more people have heard of you and that
feeds in that works both ways
so the more people that love you and
hate you the bigger you get but here's
the good thing
the bigger bigger you get more people
love you more people hate you but all
the people that hate you
they can't affect you because they can't
make the people love you
give them take the money back or put
tickets back or put the dvds back on the
shelf
so they're irrelevant they don't count
they're not coming to your house
they don't like you so concentrate on
the you know these
and then the next project you have to
start again you mustn't try and please
these
you know you just have to do it for
yourself
because there's no other reason well
apart from getting paid
i mean getting paid is fun but having
self-respect is important as well isn't
it and
it is you know this creative process
because we were just saying beforehand
as well like
where you get your ideas from at this
stage because it feels like obviously
the office you drew from experience
extras or celebrity in the experience
yeah and derek to my knowledge you had
family who worked in that five or six
yeah so now
we're thinking are you walking around
with the power just every interaction
you have with people
starbuck's just going can i just stop
you there what's your name i've always
done that
right i've always people watched from
the age of five or six so i lear
most things i you know i became an
atheist not through
um i was into science but not through
studying theology through body language
when i was
about eight years old i loved jesus i
thought it was brilliant i thought it
was great
of course he was i i thought was a
superhero
even with a god thing i thought no he's
he was kind and he was strong and he
stood up and he got back i thought
that's
he's [__] this jesus he's the dude
yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i i thought it was great
right um and i did believe i thought
yeah god made
all that i i don't think i don't know
what you
really believe eight years old and
probably something similar to
santa you don't go into it right so
someone tells you it and that's it
good babysitter as you said exactly yeah
yeah that's exactly it for a working
class mum jesus is an unpaid babysitter
if i can't watch you someone can they
think it's for the good right but my
brother came in he was 11 years older
than me
um and he just said why'd you believe in
god
and my mom went bob and i knew
oh she's she doesn't want to say
something and i thought why is that
okay and then i thought about oh oh it's
not real is it
it's not real it's not real and then and
then everything
fell into place you know yeah this and
that and that
um uh but i've never i've never um
worried about spirituality i've never
people think that an atheist is
going around running into churches and
saying it's all bollocks i don't
give a fuc honestly you know i talk
about it in my new show that you know
um uh i have no problem with belief i
just don't
i just don't believe that that's it it's
sort of a big subject right now though
isn't it because there's people like
jordan peterson and um
you know uh dawkins those going around
giving talks about the nature of what
how can you be spiritual if you don't
have a god which is what a lot of
religious people say
and you sort of address it in this
series there's a woman in your office
who's like
you know well what happens when you die
then these kind of things who ask what's
the reasons
well i think the spirituality in a
religious term is
wow look at all this amazing stuff god
made
that's amazing the mountains are amazing
animals are amazing
they're amazing right i go yeah i feel
the same they're amazing yeah i just
don't think he made them
yeah so there's no difference in our
spirituality we're just arguing about
where it came to because i can
i can get that and i think it's
explainable i understand evolution and
and you know a little bit of quantum
physics and all those things so
i have the same feelings they do i just
think oh what you call god i call nature
yeah i call gravity
i call chance i call uh you know yeah
and you do like the white people up
about it a little bit though that's just
i just love that but i do that about
everything yeah there's that i've got no
bigger
chip in my shoulder about religion than
i have teasing
someone about their tattoos i wouldn't i
wouldn't tease someone that big
about their tattoos that's i have a
simple rule yeah people like t's
have to be smaller it's fine
what you have to do is work up a close
relationship with them and then
afterwards just like poke him and she's
not even looking at him in the face
because
i was looking at you yeah exactly just
look for the cuck in the room you know
what i don't mean that's what you do
but actually when we found uh where
people found out that you were coming on
here they were like oh
a bit of an [__] isn't he like me a
bit worried actually like
i said how's this going to go but like
everyone i know like we're friends with
chuck mate who
you've done stuff with everyone i know
speaks really highly but are you aware
that there's this image of you that
people are a bit
interviewing you might be a bit of a um
i
i am because um i i think that uh
early days some journalists have said uh
i'm combative
and i go well no i just put you right
you know i mean
if they say and uh and you said oh no i
didn't say that i said this like i go oh
okay do you want my answer or what yeah
it's like
someone can slag you off and if i answer
back so i'll go oh he's thin-skinned
hold on no no no no you well i can't i
mustn't
ever answer back or i'm the thin skinned
one surely you should be able to stand
up for
you know your rights and um it's funny
because i think
um with all the advantages that people
think that comes with fame celebrity
they actually think you have less rights
yeah they have they don't like property
you don't have rights to
uh privacy you shouldn't answer back
you shouldn't you know have the normal
emotions of everyone else because you're
you're somehow
you've got a real practical approach a
celebrity like you you don't seem to
value it
the way and i mean it was shown when you
[__] hosted the globes and that
is this partly because of your like
working class background maybe
it's a working class background and i
was 39
when fame came to me it didn't define me
i know somebody
if you're famous from the age of 15 or
want to be famous for 15 or 20 or
it it sort of defines you because that's
the world you live in you think
everything
everyone acts like that you pick up the
symptoms you're worried about going out
you're worried about being packed you're
worried about your hair
you're worried about you you know where
you are in the chat
it's madness it's a game it doesn't mean
anything so
if you if you come to it and you've um
you know already lived a life
it it's frivolous to me it's getting a
table at a restaurant
which i could probably do anyway if i
bothered you know but getting in the
queue
so it's those things this is madness you
know it
to worry put such value in celebrity
and also there's no difference now
between fame and infamy
it's like celebrities used to be oh
they're great they've done some really
great things and we all love them
now it can be we all hate them but
they're bringing a book out
you know they get rewarded for shitty
behavior too now
just being [__] yeah gets do you know
what i mean
it's the new god though alongside my
friend said why would you walk in and
buy
the only way is essex autobiography when
nelson mandela is like right there do
you know what i mean like there's
mandela and you go well jordan's outsold
yeah she's a pretty prolific lifestyle
you know yeah the one i liked the best
thing about jordan was
she was interviewed about her biography
and said now i don't know if this is in
the autobiography
yeah so not only did she not write it
she didn't read it yeah i mean
just put it out definitely read my old i
love it i
just want to check yeah i put that in
what did i do in 1997 yeah oh yeah she's
the ultimate though she is the ultimate
of that
she was one of the original people who
just made was made famous for being
famous but you know what i've still got
nothing against them i've got nothing
against the kardashians because what
they've done is they've
they've um uh created the life they want
i think i mean what's dangerous is
people look at them and going well i can
do that and you're sort of right
um but you know with all the with all
the things like you know
x factor and britain's got talent and
these things where you go on and juggle
a sink
um it's like that now what you've named
the wrong thing there again because
i paid to see someone juggle this thing
the thing that i
i think why you are maybe a dangerous
figure within to those people
is that you're a lot of this relies on
the emperor's clothing idea of like
people going back oh the clothes look
good and everyone goes yeah they look
really good don't they so when you're
willing to go
about me no but when you're willing
massive balls or long balls
but when you're willing to go no you're
just doing this [__] thing
they go don't tell anyone and also the
other thing about the golden globes was
i didn't have anything against them
it was just jokes that's yeah the
shocking thing was that they didn't get
they were just
jokes you know i didn't know about uh
i went about their behavior not about
things they couldn't help things they'd
done in public i wasn't you know
so all it was was gentle teasing that
some people can't handle this story
it's weird because yeah we've made we
make jokes about other youtubers and i
get private messages dude like
what did you say that phone is like you
made a [__] video
like you but no one ever tells people
that so when they hear
constructive real criticism that they
fully deserve but everyone else
they read in the comments i love it
brilliant and it is actually [__] when
they hear that it's like
and i imagine it's only 100 times worse
when you're brad pitt or whoever the
[__]
yeah it's a shock to the system for
these people
yeah i don't know why they would care i
i don't know why they would
uh you know people and some of them most
of them didn't that's not you know
those people sitting there okay i was
about the joke yeah whatever
it's no big deal i i'm a millionaire and
i'm going back to it i don't but so all
people make them care they go oh this
though we made a fool of you did he oh
okay then there's some people looking
around wondering if they could laugh
at someone else because they're beholden
to them because they're a director or
producer
i'm not beholden to anyone i create my
own labor i own my own labor so i don't
care
having said that i never went out there
to hurt anyone's feelings or undermine
the moral fabric of america
they were jokes they just hadn't seen it
done before and i suppose i played the
outsider a little bit which you've got
to do
which you have to do to be a comedian i
think particularly
uh the strain of where british comedy is
has evolved we were usually the court
jester we were we were the idiot
um what making the other idiots laugh at
someone who's better off that we had
low status but now people know how much
we earn
so it's hard to keep your low status so
i don't want to go out there and pretend
that uh
or signing on yesterday yeah you know
that bus driver [__]
you [__] lie i've been on the bus for
40 years right
so i keep it real and i keep my lower
status in two ways
one i invite them in i go what you think
it's all fun and games meeting the queen
look what i i piss myself you know or
something i invite them in and go i was
the putts so they laugh at that
the other thing i do is i talk about
things where they're better off than me
i talk about being fat and old and going
bald and gonna die before them and saggy
balls
and they're going i'm better off so you
do it you do it you can still do it
and you shouldn't go out there and be
above the audience you should go out
there and tell the audience what a great
life
you've had there's nothing more boring
but you're right mate yeah yeah right
we've had a bad day here
so i do ironically oh yeah some of the
biggest laughs
i i pretend you know i'm so rich i can
have this place burnt down for a laugh
because they know it's a joke
they know this is more than mostly the
truth
you know what i mean yeah even more than
most comedians or you've
you've went out of your way to be like i
guess if you compare you like
seinfeld or chris rock or like they
still
they care a bit more about their image
and i think you really didn't give a
[__] like you actually embraced that
even more so
um well i wan again uh when i started
i remember thinking um the point of
stand up and the people are liked right
um uh i want to be nearly as funny
as everyone is in the pub with their
mates and that
that people think well i can do that you
can't it's really hard
it's really hard to go out on stage 10
000 people and be as funny as you are
in the pub with your mates right because
you can't say the things you say in the
pub with your mate
you have to explain too much to be as
funny as because they've known you for
10 years
so one little look can be the funniest
thing you know you know what your mates
thinking
someone comes in you make looks and you
laugh because you know what he's
thinking
you can't do that right so it's harder
than it
than it the and um uh i wanted to
i remember thinking this as well um 20
years ago i wanted to fuse that
perfection of seinfeld where he takes an
idea and he goes to the lo
and and explore that but do it like
billy connolly
shambling out in jeans with a beer
saying how i
i've just come from the docks that's
what i wanted uh
and i didn't have a thing i didn't have
a thing
i i haven't set myself a light in a
brothel like richard pryor
you know i haven't been uh oppressed
yeah so what's my only thing being a
a an a working-class oic who shouldn't
be
in polite society i still play that even
though they know i went to university
and every night
i still play the it gives a [__] who
gives a [__]
yeah i know i shouldn't be here um and
with stand up i still
i just i always try and get in where
i've come from stories from childhood or
making a fool of myself or a teacher
putting me down or my dad
that because that it goes in it all goes
in
subliminally they go ah well you pass
that down as well though like
how to deal with certain situations like
we were talking fun
and it's like we usually
like people would be bullied at school
yeah and we'd have no reply to them i
mean i wasn't bullied that much i've got
to be honest but
this one's my story you've told me a few
of these stories yeah
you were my tools yeah oh sorry and i'm
not you know what you're saying there
but i said this before like you
there were kids at school uh when the
office first came out
who they how old are you uh 30 just
right right so you're like you were i
was in the end
right here and i think the first time it
came out a lot of i remember when people
my mum went i can't watch this
documentary like she turned off and
didn't like it didn't like the boss
that's great it was a bit like
this guy's an [__] and i was like oh
but i i didn't and i remember watching
it thinking
i don't know if this is a comedy or if
this is a documentary at the time
because it was so
felt so real that's great and then when
i watched it as a comedy
over time i'd start going you know when
a bully did something in class i go oh
that's so and people and everyone else
to go
he's he's subtly
we're all just copying what you did
basically like me and him
have taken a lot from yourself are you
aware of the impact that you had on
our generation yeah uh i sort of
i sort of um
straight after i noticed that adverts
were doing
fake documentary yeah but again i didn't
invent that i mean uh
you did in this style i know we're
trying to be like oh ricky it's so great
the way you did it but
there there is a generation of people
now where you can look at them in the
eye they'll do one
brent quote and everyone you instantly
go i like you do you know what i mean i
think that's
i think that's more mine the fact that
because i wasn't a real actor what i was
doing was an impression
of a man i made up i always thought of
like what would this guy do
not how to act or where to stand but
what would this guy do
and once you understand the motivation
of brent that he's
he wants to be popular he wants to be
popular right and there's a camera there
so that's going to catch him being a
[__] as well once you understand that
everything makes sense if that wasn't a
fake documentary
that would be a very very average sitcom
be very very average hello
yeah yeah you know but once you know he
wants to be famous
yeah and he's getting caught out so i i
i i hated exposition i hated how people
like to say
um john you know your sister the one who
went to gambia yeah well of course
she's my sister why are you talking
about that so uh and it made it harder
because you couldn't you couldn't you
know do things behind closed doors
because
so it made you work and so i did it with
getting caught by the camera so if
someone says something and they go
uh is that true and you go you know
they're lying
you just know they're lying you had an
ability to bring it make it more real
than i think other people had done
beforehand because you i guess because
you weren't trained
and you knew you just made it more like
real life yeah i was emulating
um those sort of quaint docu-soaps that
of the nineties that i'd watched you
know and or no
ordinary people get their 15 minutes of
fame and yeah and that was exactly
but then now it's
when i came to do um life on the road it
was like 10 times
worse you know now david brent would
have
been on x factor or and so i made it
harder for him that he thought
he was no generation and thought well
now i'm gonna do it the right way and of
course he struggled even more
yeah um but uh it it it's got
crazier and crazier now people will you
know do anything
to be famous what's your motivation at
this point then because like you've
you've done everything you've made lots
of money like obviously
you can pick and choose everything you
want to do but you seem to be still
grinding away doing all these stand-ups
and serious
why aren't you just chilling out in the
beach somewhere well i am i mean i i'm
not on a beach but
um this is it's still fun
for me it's i get up every day and i do
what i want
i mean that's that's rare and if i don't
want to do it i don't do it
and as soon as i have if i finish a
project i think oh i've done that right
i'm gonna have a rest
when i rest is when i think of another
idea the
the having the idea is the buzz for me
that's the thrill and is there a way you
get those ideas stereotypically
you can't it can't you've got the sort
of brain and it comes to you
but um what gets harder because i do
everything
and i like to do more than one project
because i've got that sort of brain i
can't do one project
because i can only work on it for 20
minutes and then go now what and i'll go
some computer chess
i'll go out and find a dog to play with
so i have
i have three paintings on the go right
so i can go from one to the other and i
can keep my brain
it's just i can't help that that's i
don't even know what that is right
but i need to do that um my motivation
it's fun i can you know when i push
myself i go
can i get away with that is there a way
of getting away with that i think i can
i think i know um and uh it comes to you
when you relax and it's
this is my job now i mean that's
incredible yeah this is our job
we were doing this anyway i did this on
the dole yeah
this is what i was doing the much you
know yeah
yeah you know um so uh
but there's admin because i still have
to take care of business that's the
thing you don't
you know talk about you know um so every
day
if i if i do a six hour day which is
[__] rare that's a
long day but four and a half hours is
admin
yeah just go and do that do that what
so-and-so yeah okay tell them
okay what have i got to do i got because
i do it all
right so the best time for me
is as i lay down to sleep
um on a plane altitude
um no phone and champagne and i write
that's when i write the things that make
you cry that's when i write the bits
that make you cry
and i'm there on a plane anyway yeah i'm
fine
thanks right he didn't say that in first
class i think you make me cry worse
though because
you've brought me so many laughs that
i'm more emotionally connected to you as
a friend
so when you get upset i it really gets
me going whereas
my family said that yeah and another
nephew said they oh
when i cry they cry because they know me
of course and they and they've
they've never seen me cry you know
except a funeral you know so
um but uh i'm going for a run
um yes i do yes i do yes i do
all right i work out every day imagine
if i didn't
um uh but yeah you just think the
endorphins kick in you're there for 20
minutes no phone
you're thinking about things and that's
usually jokes that's usually a routine
or a thing
that i think of that's my that's my
naughtiest when i go oh
that's funny that's funny i go home i
say to jane
what do you think of this she says
please don't do that and then i know
i know there's something over there
that's it that's the one yeah
fantastic i love it if she says the two
buttons that's the that's spot on
so and then i'll go okay what with this
he goes right yeah i have to get round
so see first you go unfiltered
and then you go now i'll make it
palatable about that then i've gotta
make it bulletproof
because this joke can come back and
haunt me in ten years you don't want it
you shouldn't have to worry about it
you don't want to be james corden harvey
weinstein type jokes whether
exactly he hadn't thought it through
yeah he wasn't it wasn't his thing you
know
i want to say you know again i wouldn't
slag him off for doing it
but you know if you are you're not oh
you've got to be bulletproof and then
you can't say sorry
you say sorry i don't say sorry you
should've done the [__] first place
what you ten
right so i want to say i want to say to
people who aren't uh comedians haven't
been doing all their life you shouldn't
try this at home
yeah people say how does he get away
with it well because i [__] think
about it
i haven't gone out there i'm gonna drunk
and said something horrendous
i've thought about that joke more than
your article about it yeah i've i've
played that joke
to us 800 000 people you're going to do
a snotty blog
[__] off when i watch humanity
there was the joke about um the baby
dying and how incapable of a parent you
were
yeah and i thought myself oh that's so
[__] funny for a star
after i'd stopped laughing but after a
while i'm like and i really thought
about
is there anything you could say about
that like or you could bring up and
and you cannot take you to task because
you've literally done what it's also
so many it's my baby that doesn't exist
exactly so imagine someone getting
annoyed at that yeah
i want some i once tweeted uh um right
i've put on seven pounds and a picture
of me with a big belly
um do your worst insult me
right people said you shouldn't fat
shame
what me why okay my bad
yeah it's it's ludicrous what people get
upset about but they haven't again they
haven't thought it through
because twitter's turbo twitter is
before you've thought about it oh yeah
it's just easily true
15 years ago you go i'm going to
complain dear bbc
i can't be bothered yeah now you fire it
off now it's that is road rage
you're going fast and i think the human
nature is
more to speak only when something's
annoyed you and not as much when
so if we watch the comments on this
video you're gonna get
more negative probably than positive a
lot of the time because if you're
enjoying it you're not
you're not writing you're you're sitting
there and enjoying it i know generally
that is but
again but the type of people who will go
online and leave a comment
that is like you might as well go and
read toilet walls to get upset about
them
i i i have never been upset by anyone on
twitter i have no one has ever upset
they don't exist it's like me honestly
they think they can i'm too happy
if i'm walking down the street and
there's some [__] in a bin covered in
[__] and he shouts wanker i'm gonna get
upset of course i'm not
it would be madness it would be woodland
i just don't think he's covered in [__]
his imagination no wonder
not to always go back to your comedies
and what you put on tv but
that's what i always like about your
character is that there's a
vulnerability but they think they're not
vulnerable yeah so greg doesn't think
he's vulnerable
also it exaggerates them it can be
totally wrong there's no irony
yeah people can get it wrong i remember
when i first got on twitter i did a
tweet right and somebody said so i was
like okay no i didn't mean that
and i'd spend the next hour explaining
that i thought
[__] off why am i doing this and then
people go
dude don't explain to them they're a
[__] [__] most of us got
of course you did yeah why am i it's
honestly it's like going out and doing
an arena
and going somewhere do you like it oh i
don't like it
okay it's council show that what do you
like yeah what do you like
joke was funny okay just let me break
this down because i see the baby's dead
but it's not real so
yeah i know but you it's like i did used
to worry about it because i thought
oh they've got it wrong and uh and i'll
still explain the joke
if they want if someone's asked me a
genuine question on twitter
i would explain i don't always have to
be flipping or turning the [__] off or
block them or whatever um
i used to get so annoyed that people
would say uh
to me things like um uh over evolution
i used to discuss things on twitter um
and they say
oh okay if we evolved um from apes then
why are there still apes around yeah and
i used to go oh you [__]
and now i say i just i just answer i go
no we didn't evolve from apes we evolved
with apes from a common ancestor
rather like cousins and that
one thing that struck me when i was
watching because it really reminded me
of right after
uh someone died in my life and how i was
acting i was like it's as if
this is about me here i couldn't believe
it how did you
how did you know like where you go like
have you
have those experiences yourself or well
i'm uh
i haven't had i mean the greatest fear
is
it you know is your life partner that
you know that's that's the be a
end all there's nothing like i've had
parents and
friends but um uh no so it
you know i'm um i'm guessing uh
but uh that was all just pretty much you
imagining it then
yeah i didn't talk to anyone
specifically or see anyone who
inspired that uh no but again
i have i know i've everyone knows
someone who's you know and uh and you've
got anecdotes and
and uh i've heard interviews with uh
people i admire who've lost their
partner and uh so it all goes in you
don't even have to think about it
because
at the end of the day is a fiction as
long as you do something that has
happened or could happen
um you don't have to something that
happens every day to everyone
that's boring um uh and then i still
have to make it funny
and then i have to you know throw lots
of things in there's a thousand stories
in there
and i and i just did one um
but i do i do like it to be real i do
like to be honest and real
and i do like people to connect in any
way i i do
i think the greatest thing about art is
connecting
um with a stranger somebody you'll never
know or me or not
you know um or care about in a way
i don't know these people um but it is a
thrill to think that
uh you're like you're like um
you're downloading emotions and that's
why music comes in it's like
you're making someone a thousand miles
away
feel somewhat you know and and now with
social media i do hear about it
oh my god just watch derek i'm a 54 year
old builder crying my eyes out yeah you
know
that's lovely that's a really lovely
thing to hear
um uh so um but you mustn't you mustn't
second guess you know i um i don't know
who i like it and i imagine people like
different things
people would put my a thousand people
with my work in different order
of their favorites to you know i do it
you know i you know
how do you feel about personal no i
don't i don't know tomorrow
can i change your mind about that as
well yeah and also everything bleeds
into that
you know it's like um you can have a
real affection
for the first thing you ever did but no
it's not the best thing you ever did
you know it's you know you're speaking
about the office and how you sort of it
wasn't
like now you're you're speaking about
your work in a totally different way
than when you were first making the
office and
you are yeah trying to impersonate a guy
rather than
now you're creating all this emotion and
you're really thinking things through
differently
what was the biggest learning experience
of your life so far to get you
to oh like you upgraded a lot through
that time what was the thing that you
think would be like
that was the one i really learned from
the most what project
or thing moment anymore or any anything
that really
you feel like made you improve the most
as a person meeting jerry seinfeld don't
meet your [__] heroes
oh my god oh that's
uh well lots of things
um uh
i suppose uh
knowing christopher guest
there's lots of he's been a sort of
mentor and i have to give him props in a
spinal tap fake documentary yeah um
and he's and he he's given me some pills
i like the way
he acts and conducts himself um
i remember once when i had to do a there
was an invention lion they wanted me to
do one of those um
uh screenings where you they give you
notes
the 40 members of the public give you
notes and i thought i don't want to do
that
right and christopher said why would you
they said um if if you're going to let
them edit it for you next time write it
with them
i thought that's a lovely thing to do
it's a lovely thing to say
you know um uh but you learn
all the time you learn all the time and
because
i mean i suppose i've done a bit of
learning before i came to it
um that life experience life experience
i remember i
won the bafta the first batter i won for
the office
and i was sat at home with it and i
after you know
being a quite an underachiever
i was very good at underachieving and i
said to jane ah why didn't i do this
before
and she went we would have been any good
you didn't have anything to say
what you've got you've got a i couldn't
done it at 22 or 23.
life's already too good at 20. you have
to come
to terms with your own inadequacies you
know
it's i think that or whether
um the simon amstel said uh
uh when he sees a really good looking
young comedian
he thinks why do you want to do this
people are already looking at you
and that's a lovely thing to think you
know
exactly yeah
yeah exactly um yeah i had to uh i had
to get
i had to lose my looks well because i
was going to say at one point i think it
could have been so different for you
imagine if you got that that's the
biggest lesson [__] up that's the
biggest lesson by far the biggest lesson
that's it number one that i wanted to be
a pop star
and i should have wanted to be a
musician and then when i came to this
i knew i wanted to own my own labor and
create the work i want to be the writer
director
the acting was whatever the being on
the red carpet whatever my fat face on
the screen whatever
but doing owning the work that that's
that was my biggest lesson i should have
i should have wanted to be a musician
you know i should have wanted to be
radio ahead not
you know you know what i mean yeah not a
boy band um and i didn't particularly
but you know that that's certainly a
lesson yeah it is funny for me um i
thought your biggest lesson was going to
be there were a scarf like that in a
picture but the um
the other part is a lovely scarf in
curve
no picture in the picture of you in the
world i sort of spoofed
that picture a little bit incur that
little white chiffon scarf that um
i looked at that and i was like is that
a tribute to his younger self
now that was great fun as well because
i'd done it to other people
yeah for years in extras and they've got
and then when i get the chance to do it
to myself
i realize why people love it when people
say how did you get people to do that
it's a day off for them yeah and they're
sort of going well
the best thing to do with it is make
yourself worse than they want you to be
so if you go crazy you're basically
saying
see i'm not i can't be really like this
can i yeah you know so
that was an absolute joy doing curb and
being a complete
arrogant [__] that was so much fun
it's funny because actually i don't
think
you get as much credit in extras for
your writing as you do in the office
because
well it's so real but the comedy writing
in extras not to sound like too
significant but
i think it's because innovation gives
you that stuff because they hadn't seen
anything quite like before and they
hadn't seen me before so i get new props
yeah and mckellen to say how do i act so
well yes [__]
brilliant like that's still one of my
favorite comedy scenes i i i'm glad you
said that and i i
do sort of agree with you because um uh
it was sort of easier in a way because
we had
we had the famous people to spoof so
that that's a
again that's a little bit easier because
they're doing a lot of the work just by
being there
and being you could just sit there half
an hour and be like what's the most
crazy [__] i can get
of course you can still blow it though
it could still be awful i've seen people
have them in there i just think we
haven't done you haven't done anything
with that yeah you know you can make it
like a
children in need sketch where you go you
had so and so and you and that's all you
did
oh come on you know so you could still
blow it um
but extras was really still about some
hapless people
you know it was never meant to be about
celebrities that was for realism rather
like
we had real computers and paper around
in the office yeah they were no more
than that
in a way because it was about a man
struggling to be accepted and uh
and i remember when uh that was a
conscious decision i wanted to play the
opposite of david brent because david
brent
um hits the blind spot we're laughing at
you know um he thinks this person is not
whereas andy millman
he's him isn't he he's a very exactly
he's the tim and he's very aware
of his inadequacies and he's angry about
it so that's a different funny
yeah it's a different funny it's just as
funny someone who's delusional thinks
they're great and you're laughing about
great right but someone who goes my life
is absolutely [__] [__]
you know that's why the last tennis
episode was great effect harry
and there's there's a lot of courses of
[__] lives
yeah of course exactly yeah but uh again
i mean you've got a
i think you've got there's got to be a
struggle yeah there's got to be a
struggle
because initially andy miller will start
i like those wise crackers and
i want him to be like um you know
groucho marx or bob hope you're one of
those people that but again even there
it they sort of show that it's not good
to be the cleverest person in the room
you know the lisa sin uh simpson
syndrome that you can do a
what you can't if you'll go where you're
an idiot either we'll because we're not
like you know bart simpson gets a round
of applause because he you know
um so there was that as well so all
these factors you have to
why are people laughing you might you
know people have to sort of
know even it's only intuitively why
they're laughing
you know derek how long did it take you
to perfect
who he was going to be because i'm sure
you played around with him a lot what
was that like
um yeah it was an evolution that
originally started
uh as a character um
i it was gonna be i had him for
for a while um but it was gonna be him
saying those funny things
to celebrities because i've had them as
long as the 11 o'clock show
wow so he was going to go out and go out
to so i say
why did you do rubbish film right so
they'd be disarmed by this nice guy
and i'd and i'd seen autograph hunters
and they're a sweet bunch but they're an
odd bunch
and they're all lovely and sweet but an
odd one
you know any statement yeah well they
were so i i
and i thought oh that would be great
because i don't know them and when you
get no they're really sweet and nice
right they just look odd because they're
right in the rain in another round you
know they're drenched
right like any of those so i thought
after a signature they could be
they could have amazing lives they could
be really wise they'd just like
so i thought that's great so i'm going
to make derrick to look at him
someone you go who and then you go
actually he's he doesn't care about this
so he's quite zen
i've got him quite zen i quite like that
you know you know the the sort of the
the the anger the the hobo turns out to
be god
it makes it
yeah and he's just he's you can't you he
he
i wish he existed i i've never had a
connection with playing a character like
derek
well i think that was your best acting
performance in my opinion oh thank you
i think it's you know it's most
obviously not just me
yeah it was it was the biggest stretch
but you nailed it yeah
and i think them i think people think
and they're right um
that i'm lazy uh when it comes to how
long am i in the makeup chair and uh
i got offered i got offered um that
winston churchill film oh really
quarterback
no no no and i went i said uh and
there's a bit you go yeah maybe i could
do it
but then then of course you couldn't
they need a re-enactor i
i was saying to them you need a real
actor i think they'd seen me do church
and i was surprised like you said not
that because you are a big imperial and
then
and then um um jane read the script and
she went you know he's 62 in this so you
probably have to have makeup three i
won't forget it
that was it that was i would have
enjoyed that though because uh
you're a little bit like um robin
williams and that you
i he could do what both you know you
could do it all
and i don't know i would have enjoyed
that i yeah i think
sometimes it's um it's too
it's too much effort or too hard or i
don't think i'm the genuinely best
person for the job
whereas if i create the character it
comes from me
it's already there so i am the best
person for the job um
and uh um yeah i just think that uh
i think if i if i'm doing my own
mannerisms and i'm not worried about
doing an accent or a funny walk or
a hunchback i can make it realer for
them even though they might think oh
he's just
he's just playing himself that's a
ridiculous accusation all my favorite
people played themselves
dustin hoffman plays himself lauren
hardy played themselves same and
everything woody allen is always the
same
it's this this thing that that to be a
great actor you have to transform
yourself and live in a cage for a year
it's
you don't you know you don't know
ironically the
the method is what they do is they
imagine that person and what they would
do in their spare time that's exactly
what you did with brent
but you weren't aware of it probably at
the time no i wasn't aware of it i had
no i didn't i hadn't picked any uh
acting sim i still don't
i still i can still i can still cry
in tears have the camera people in tears
and they go right okay next
next shot is um and then they're
freaking out that looks weird
yeah of course they've got to slowly put
the brakes on and go back into
right because again it's a real emotion
but um i'm always thinking
i'm thinking oh this is start again or
you've got to
you've got to think this is good and i i
every time i've cried eventually lying
david brent derek afterlife every time
i've cried
it's the first take because then you
feel better
i can't do a second take crying yeah you
can't because once you go there
you can't because i you have to if you
cry they're real tears
i don't mean i'm really upset and the
other thing is it's got to be justified
i couldn't cry here because i'm not
thinking about somebody's
so if if i was doing something and it
wasn't justified
it's not sad enough i can't cry so
i suppose that's a bit of method um but
you just make sure you make
sure what you've written justified
someone crying anyway otherwise it's
nonsense it's it's soap opera do you
want a lot you seem to run a lot of
things by
jane do you yeah you go with her with
almost everything that you do do you
well she makes me think i mean i don't i
you know um
uh yeah i think i think she'd probably
have seen everything
i've ever done before i've done it at
some stage
so you're like first audience member
basically uh yeah
uh particularly with jokes no one knows
by i'm not excited about it
and uh and and and it's not like it's
not really a test i'm not really going
if she hates this it's brilliant
sometimes you go
oh you said so oh yeah good point good
point yeah so
you do need that um the great thing
about stand-up is
um it's not like other disciplines so
when you write a film or a sitcom or and
you do your best thing and you think
about it and you might show it to a few
people and you film it and you read it
and you and then it's finished and it's
out there's nothing you can do about it
that's it
done right with stand up you can change
it every night
and they choose your best bits they
choose your best bits for you
so it's less like an art and more like a
science it either works or it doesn't
if it works keep that in add to it if it
doesn't work
think about it lose it already so what
you're
after 10 gigs to
a couple hundred people at a time um
you've got the best hour
and if an audience of a thousand people
here like it it works the same there of
different it
people are the same if they can
understand the language they're the same
that's a big sample a thousand people
and so once it works it works every
night even states in england
so or did you change your act for this
thing no i don't change that you know
the only thing that i do is it is if
it's um
again a cultural reference right so the
punchline was
kerry katona right they do so you either
do an equivalent
or you lose it or you you you know and
so but no i don't
you don't need to change tap to force it
and pavement to the sidewalk you know
how many people do you meet um who
haven't quite got which makes sorry
which makes me make sure that that is
um universal and timeless yeah so you
don't know
so i don't i don't go see your big
brother last night on that i go no
we didn't yeah you know so you do the
bible
the side of it is how many people have
you met because i meet a lot of people
who
don't quite get you or they don't quite
understand your humor
and sometimes we have a word for those
thoughts
no no no but seriously there are people
who think they get you
and they go to your stand up and they go
oh it's bloody brilliant but i get you
in a different way to the way that some
of those people get well that's
that that's yes um i'm not saying i get
you in the right way but there's a lot
of people
i love and and uh and um
yeah i i know what you mean and and i
feel it sometimes because
um when uh
and it depends what i've done as well
because once you're in like
a hollywood movie or you do the golden
globes there are people who haven't seen
the office
or seen a stand-up and so um if they've
seen me
um being fun and nice on this morning
at saying things you know you're saying
about your nan and then they're gonna
watch humanity
yeah brilliant
so you get those but most people get it
and and and the great thing about
humanity
i've been around for so long that
everyone there got me they know who you
are they know who i am now they know
they they
and they laugh at the if i do anything
even slightly self-referential or
uh talk about money or do a joke about
you know
being self-aware of my image or anything
they they all laugh they get it so so
you come through the other side really
but yeah um certainly throughout
and early on uh so people would love the
office they want to get a ticket
right and then i'll do a chat show then
i win an award so
next time i do twice as big a venue and
now some of them haven't seen the office
or
so they're they're not quite sure but
you know you go by the way what you
don't do is try and please them right
they either
they're either go away or their seats go
to someone who does care next time
right and all you have to do is make
sure that you could have sold more
tickets that's what i do
i don't i i i sell enough
i sell enough and i've got the world as
well so most companies haven't got the
world
so i don't have to do 13 nights in
blackpool yeah because
you know i can who wants no deny me yeah
yeah yeah because i know i i can play
i can play around the world i can play
north america what about when you have
bombed
what i've felt like can you help me a
lot better does that ever happen
well it's difficult because what you
mean by bombed
when you bomb is not usually your
audience
so when i jump up and say jokes at the
golden globe so
some people gasp i don't know if that's
bombing
because i i i remember in the
traditional way like maybe in the early
days what
if that happened well i didn't do the
early days my first
gig was animals
and the first gig the first gift i did
animals the warm-up
i was on the front cover of the radio
times
as the most influential person in comedy
which is obviously ludicrous
but i'd done i was on this about to do
the second series of the office and i'd
won two batters
so no one no one going there was going
oh the [__] this bloke they're going i
love the office he's my favorite
so you've never really had that classic
standard experience
i haven't no yeah and i and uh no i
really haven't
uh so i'd have to i'd have to sort of
create it really and i don't know where
i could go to create it because there's
going to be someone who
tried doing animals in a church i think
that'll probably do it well
yeah you can say you could you can
certainly find
not you know i imagine if i i can't
imagine
um if i supported another comedian for a
laugh
that might not go down but it's
it's it's hard for me now to know what
it would have been like
but it makes me work harder because you
don't want
the cheer when you walk out to be louder
than the cheer when you walk
so i try and lower expectations i
sometimes do it ironically
with a big thing and then go anyway
don't get your hopes up
you know but you'd feel that
if if you if you're the biggest comedian
on the planet and they're going mental
for you
and then you do an okay show like oh
[__] me yeah
you relax people when you come out
you've got i don't know where you
[__] buy this massive count of
uh do you have them customers yeah right
that i tell when that started so uh um
it was uh the first special
for hbo um out of england two which is
sort of a compilation of my first two
shows animals and politics right
because i thought i'd have to lose so
much i didn't want to do animals and
politics because i
so i lost all the poker things and they
made a great hour yeah
and i was on hbo um and
uh i said that the people do you want a
beer out there
yeah yeah um uh just a oh just a uh
account of fosters right
and i didn't realize that actually
fosters in new york was quite hard to
get
yeah right so they went they and i
didn't know this was happening guy i
meant a beer
right so we've got you fostered went
great and i went uh and
they had these ridiculously large cans
so i went out there to take the thing
and i went and i went
could i just explain to people um that
is a really big cat i am not a dwarf
yeah
right and then whenever i went people
had a count of fosters for me people
thought i was sponsored
by five and it's just stuck it's just
that's
first yeah that's how it happened yeah
you've seen none of the kickbacks so i'm
just getting annoying
i've never had a free i've never had a
free can of fosters ever could have made
you a millionaire that i know yeah yeah
yeah what's it like to be in
or to be because uh how to phrase this
question
you didn't do the sets you didn't go
jobbing around you know across in south
london in all the london places
what's it like to then suddenly sit on a
special with uh jerry seinfeld chris
rock and lucy k
going we're all comedians he's brilliant
he's brilliant
you never i know you're not the kind of
guy to get imposter syndrome but what
does it feel like to
sit alongside those guys uh well by then
i was sort of and i had done a few and
also
the chat was gonna be about comedy in
general yeah it was i wanted to talk
about
seinfeld and uh uh um everyone hates
chris and i
i wanted to talk about louie into it and
i'll talk about the office next week
but actually when it came down to it i
was outnumbered so
they just talked about stand up yeah
because it was the thing they really
cared about and um i i went along with
the right and i remember
i think this was off air um that uh
seinfeld he couldn't understand
that the other three of us did other
things he thought we were crazy
yeah but why do you want to do he said
why do you want to do movies well i
won't do this because
you said you're a [__] stand-up and
now i get it and now
stand-up is the holy grail again it is
it is yeah i don't know why i think it's
the time that it's such a [__]
privilege to say what you want
it's there's no filter even i get final
edit on afterlife or derek or
there's still 60 people involved i still
have to worry about broadcast
rules i still have to worry about this
now whereas stand up i go when i do it
where i do it
i charge what i want [__] you don't like
it [__] off
right there's there's nothing like it
it's an absolute privilege
but you better say something interesting
those people some of them have paid 500
quid
right really and that breaks my heart
that does break my heart i want to give
them a watch
right but i bet to give them the [__]
best night of their life
so i better do something interesting and
it's not what they want right
it's what i want because again if you
second guess them you won't please
anyone
whereas if you really think uh there's a
great phrase i love
um uh to lead the orchestra
you've got to turn your back on the
audience and that
just sums up i i think are
it's not a democracy it's not you it's
it's evolution by natural selection
they are the likely they don't if they
don't someone else will buy that seat if
they don't you'll play a smaller venue
right but you but your your work you'll
still do it and you'll do it for you and
you'll feel better
um and if you can have best of both
worlds amazing
that's amazing having that audience
reaction is that part of the reason why
because you actually get that
the return straight away whereas you
know you get the comments on twitter but
you don't get to sit and watch
everyone well i realize it's because it
went even
even with right up to even up to fame
and science when i was playing i was
already playing arenas and some
and and around the world not as much as
i do now but you know
um i still felt like i'd written the
show i'd got it and then they'd come out
they'd paid
they paid in advance they paid six
months before i was sort of collecting
money
i was giving them a good show i was
going oh thank [__] for that now i can't
wait to and now i could stay there
and now i go this is and i realize they
made me work hard
because to get all that to get the money
in advance and them laughing
and then feel good afterwards it's got
to be good you can't hide you can't get
away with it
you can't but not for long i never get
nervous because if i'm going out there i
know
it's good i don't get i i wouldn't go
out there i'd cancel the show
this that's not good enough i don't put
i don't put any on sale
until the show's worked i haven't put
one gig for the new tour on sale
because i haven't finished the warm-up
[__] and i've already played to 10 000
people
at the warm-ups so i can't i when i go
out there and someone's played full
price
that i know this this works trust me it
works
it really works but not even like those
butterflies that everyone
seems to get like i get an adrenaline
rush but um
uh that's because i haven't drunk yet
and i can't wait to get out of there
because i know there's a beer
there's a lot of fosters i usually drink
at six o'clock
but when i do a gig it's ten past eight
i try to get it early sometimes i say
can we
do it just for the [__] thing no yeah
so
tempeh i'm very into that i got there
and nowadays right
like i used to wave and do a bit and
then go now i go straight up to the beer
and go
cheers [__] it straight on
there yeah i'll get you in a minute his
next one's back but i know
your point is a good one that um uh
i not so much then but uh
when i'd won the baftas and i was the
front cover radio times i did there's a
part of me that think i should have
i should i should do stand-up yeah i
sort of gotta prove my point here a
little bit
um i don't know because it was just so i
remember just that
i watched that continually over and over
again just like just
do you know with animals i that dvd
i'd done 20 shows yeah well and now i've
done
i've done 40 shows before i've put a
ticket on sale with this one yeah
because i i i loved how humanity went
the first few
uh i sort of wrote like an edinburgh
show i wrote like a writer
and i went out like an actor acting like
a stand-up
humanity i walked out i was a stand-up
and i didn't have
notes i just had a couple of things and
i just talked and i found the funny
um you still have to meet at a certain
you still have to then structure it you
have to go home and
write it but i like that way around more
and that's what i've done with super
nature as well does that come from
hanging out with comedians
because you are hanging around with
you're hanging around with the glitter
arty of
comedy from as far as most people can
tell do you know what i mean
but i'm not really i'm not you know
they see me sit down and they watch an
hour of me
with uh jerry seinfeld but it's not a
common occurrence comedians in cars not
getting coffee not your every day
if you think that i've probably spent 10
hours of my life with jerry and he's a
friend think how long
how long he spent with him today yeah
they say as well whether you know you
watch um
uh afterlife and people say oh where can
you go
where can you go from there i'll go well
you've spent two and a half hours with
that blue yeah
surely there's more to learn about him
yeah i did feel that way at the end of
afternoon i was like
oh it feels like um i remember when it
feels a bit like the sopranos
talking about sure but like it feels
like the greatest show ever i like this
in my opinion
i met him once yeah and i was
intimidated by him
yeah he's a lovely man he's huge he's
the sopranos so there's a part of you
you know as a as a as a fan he went hey
are you doing that and there's a hand
like a bear
i went good yeah you know it's he's
you're the head of the mafia yeah i'm
not an actor
in his interviews he's quite uh he was
quite a serious guy
he was he was very yeah he was yeah and
you know paulie walnuts
he's he's less of a thespian and more
he's a real gangster i don't know if he
were but yeah he went
hey funny guy i know you like that yeah
yeah how are you doing like that right
yeah
yeah yeah it's funny but what i meant by
that was
tony was developed so much over the
following seasons but we got like
i felt like we got a taste of uh the
character but
i could feel like there was more to come
if you wanted to have you ever did you
ever feel like you shut
any of the previous characters off too
early and you wanted to go further
yeah but on purpose we could have done
another series of the office but would
it have been as good
people's memories play play they plays
tricks with a no yeah because when you
think
like um uh when you think you want
another
you know it might it things happen yeah
you know and you can't leave it too long
you can't you know you can't do it too
early so
uh it it's it's really a lovely safe bet
to leave them wanting more and you never
know you never
know when you've gone too far you know
it's it's it's russian roulette like
there's
i've only done one you know well let's
just leave let's just that you got away
with that
you're not dead yeah yeah yeah you can
have too much
a phone call you had on the radio with
your mother i know
i i i do you know what i listened to
that yesterday
was it going around twitter i think uh
it came up with me recommended because
i've been watching
yeah i couldn't listen to it for ages
after yeah but now i can
just telling you i didn't bring you up
that way your language my son
i didn't bring you up to say that yeah
yeah i love how you tease her the way
you tease like jane as well
of course of course yeah yeah and then
when she laughs she always says she you
sound like mutly
um yeah that was uh that was fun
all the stories that you tell about her
like her funeral and stuff
true if i say a story is true
it's true so the whole funeral with the
she was a keen racist kind of
that's all true that's all true
everything's true um and i
i i've done jokes before that i've
dropped
that i clearly aren't true surreal
because i'm worried they think the true
stories aren't true
right right so i don't say uh i don't do
i walked into bali that i did
uh no i'm joking i don't do those so
because i want them to know that when
it's true
it's true i might change the names yeah
just in case
so a guy i went to school with who used
to suck his own dick i wouldn't say his
actual name it's actually brad pitt
yeah it's not not perfect it's not not
with his back
do you ever think um this [__] i never
went to school with anyone who sucked
their own dick no
i don't know that they might have was
the ant on the on the bell entry yeah
was that one true the fly on the bed
yeah yeah it wasn't true
he said it was true yeah you know i i
felt really tried
i've never tried i've never tried no do
you know why i wouldn't do it because i
wouldn't be cruel to an animal
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're one set of
morals you've got those little
robot wanking fly yeah not a problem
yeah pull those rings off
they don't know that's the thing you
know i felt very sorry if i felt sorry
for a lot of people
after after the office came out
uh people looked at the dynamics of the
group and they went
i am that one i am that one i always
felt sorry for the one in the group that
went
i'm gareth oh that's funny there was at
the time i put out
um i said um if you're trying to work
out which one of your
um friends is brent it's you yeah
exactly if you don't if it's not obvious
it's you yeah yeah yeah of course and by
definition we've all got a blind spot it
might it might be us we
and we all do we all do brunty things
it's just that we don't
let a film crew in and and uh we're not
so desperate
to be loved as as david brent um but
yeah
gareth well gareth is based on the guy i
went to school with who told me the fly
story and the
crab in a beer and the um if you get
captured by cannibals
they show you pornography when you're in
the pot they show you pornographic
pictures
so you get an erection and there's more
meat yeah you [__] [__]
again i changed his name yeah and he had
a mate
right he had another mate that
that was kev right in derek yeah
and so so they just talk about sex all
the time like before they'd had it
like 13 40 right and that's why gareth
is like a 14 year old boy
he was a 14 year old boy yeah so all
those things you know yeah yeah
we we we're also saying there are like
classic duvets characters in each of
your series and you can sort of see
those archetypes that you create within
each one for the different dynamics
there's always someone is a
a gareth type character there's always a
tim well stupid it is funny arrogance is
funny stupidity with arrogance is pretty
funny
on the other side anger is funny
self-awareness and you don't like it
it's funny
because you're someone trapped in their
own body like tim is funny
um so but you can't what you can't do is
have too
many i i got it all from lauren hardy
um and uh you
if you if you're doing realism you can't
have too many
crazy characters unless you only have
one sensible character
the point is this is a mad world and i'm
the only same one right
um uh likewise you can have lots of
normal characters and one crazy
character so everyone goes who the [__]
is this guy
like some mothers do have mr bean you
know so you've got to get the dynamic
right
if it's all 50 50 it's all mixed up and
everyone's got an ally
um so i i made sort of tim the lonely
one
you know the only um that would probably
be you yeah
loads of people actually so so a lot of
young people who would just discover in
the office always tweet me and go
there's you in it and i was like it's
just a white guy with a big nose that's
all it is have you got a big nose
yeah it's bigger than it's about but
it's very three minutes now we're
talking about it
now it's even worse now becomes bigger
bigger yeah can you see it
a little apparently you can but your
brain does it out
yeah yeah yeah yeah you talk about that
blind spot though i i think since being
on camera more
especially because um yours is monstrous
no but you're kind
youtube you kind of play a little bit of
a character you're turning the volume of
course
a little bit but um i've become aware of
like
myself a hell of a lot more oh yeah on
camera yeah i think i'm less ignorant
than what i was
still a little bit ignorant but yeah it
does make you a bit more sad
you must you mustn't worry about it and
you mustn't change because it'd be false
so uh yeah i mean the first time i heard
my voice
i thought why do i sound like a smurf
wuzzle
you know i thought that when i first
said your voice yeah yeah and then when
i see myself walk along the street i go
why do i
why am i waddling yeah my thighs rubbing
together am i pigeoned
right and then oh don't like that angle
there's the bald spot
come on yeah so of course it's horrible
it's it's a
i think people think that if you're
famous and you've done something you're
proud of
that you'd like to sit back and watch
yourself that's the bad bit
i'm gonna go okay get him off screen
then let's get this you know
um but uh it's it's all good it's all
it's all good all these things we worry
about they're normal they're nothing to
do with fame it's just that fame
heightens it and the problem comes with
other people's expectations of you
i mean the first time i i was asked for
an autograph right i think it was an 11
o'clock show
so i said i can have the autograph i
went really
and they felt really stupid i went
yeah oh god of course they don't they
they don't know that
this is mad for me so i went oh sure and
now
that's a lesson you know don't make
people feel stupid about liking you
yeah because they they don't know the
difference people know that people think
that everyone until he's a millionaire
immediately yeah and that they're
hanging out
with sam jackson you know that i can
confirm that's not true i've been
offered some tv stuff it doesn't pay
anywhere near as well as youtube
no no dave does pay much less
and then the the opposite end of the
spectrum is that now everyone's got a
[__] phone
so uh people can't do it give us your
phone like that yeah so
you're in a restaurant yeah people come
up like this they feel like this this is
yeah yeah yeah and just not a word
not a word yeah just like because they
um they they think you're
but when i came to it i i came to it and
i feared fame i came to it with
as i said i was 39 at the british press
i've seen them to build people up to
destroy them
and i thought right that's that that's
worrying right so
i made sure that everyone knew that i
did not sign this
deal with the devil i didn't go around
saying make me famous and you can go
through my bins
i knew that i wanted to be famous for
something and only that
i didn't do i didn't do those let people
into my house interviews or
boom i didn't do any of that [__] i went
i talk about the office
you've got to keep that there because
once you give a little yeah it's over
and now and now i can give a little bit
more because now
i know how to control well they're set
in store now we've got a slice of the
media now
you know i've got a before that was a
website if someone said something wrong
i'd go on my website and go that's not
true now i can fire off a tweet
now i've got now i've got more followers
than british newspapers you know
so i don't worry about it so much um i
don't the first time someone said a lie
about me
i thought oh my god that's not true it
wasn't anything bad you know
um it was something like um uh
yeah he's got a boxing ring and his but
i thought
what always lie what a weird lie it
doesn't worry me
you know um uh but now i don't care now
i don't care because there's so much
rubbish out there
no unless they say something that's
really bad
i i'd go no it's not no it's not true
you know
i won't even i won't even bother you
know because it's it's just not worth it
because no one cares
people have already made their mind up
if someone if someone says
it depends okay if a newspaper does a
positive thing about you
all the comments are positive if they
look negative
they're all negative they're sheep
they're just they're they're it's
meaningless like
they really i better say come up yeah
you know it's this
doesn't do that when i'm talking i feel
like i'm i mean because you're
much further down the road in your life
than that but i feel like i'm getting
like i'm nearly dead oh
yeah you're giving me life lessons yeah
i appreciate this um
and when i was looking at those i'm
great at those yeah well after i felt
like a bit like that like i was watching
it like
okay like when you're talking to the old
woman at the end and she's obviously
mourning her husband
when she's talking and i'm like this is
i can hear ricky
yeah telling me this well you're all the
characters but but more so we're
like in the office or whatever yeah it
was
now i've grown accustomed to your work
it's like i can he's telling us this so
that we learn this as well
that's right there needs to be a
character
that only has integrity that tells the
truth there needs to be one of those
um and i learned that from um
uh one of the first that started it all
for me
with binge watching and those epic sagas
about one thing
there was a a series um called murder
one
and it was 22 episodes about a court
case and the
and ever it was about lies and and
you know uh intimidated all these things
all these terrible things in
life that had happened and the lawyer um
he always told the truth and he was and
you knew when he spoke
it was almost like someone looking down
the lens and going this is the truth by
the way
this is the the real deal and i thought
you need that you need that with all the
other stuff that's happening you need
someone you go
that's that i'm having that of all the
stuff i've heard
that's the one that's the one i like um
and it usually comes from compassion and
kindness
because if someone's being kind and
compassionate and they care about you
it doesn't matter whether right or wrong
because you sort of judge people on
their intentions
um not not their final actions you know
um and we sort of know that intuitively
but sometimes we forget it
um if someone's trying to hurt you but
doesn't they're worse than someone who
accidentally hurts you
yeah yeah no doubt about it so you you
sort of do it for motivation and
intention
and that's why in comedy when the marx
brothers right they were huge involved
with their running around doing crazy
[__]
going crazy and the uh the producer came
to him and said uh
you want to do a film we've got we gotta
keep the crazy [__]
um but we do a musical number put a
little plot in and uh
uh the reason you're doing the crazy
[__] is to get these two lovers together
so now these people are doing that
without that they'd just be annoying
yeah
but people doing stupid things
but with a cause okay come on then
you're doing it for good reasons we let
people off anything
if they're doing it with good intentions
it sounds like it's
i i always watch your stuff and think
it's quite a classic story that you're
telling but just
wrapped up in quite modern trappings in
a way it is yeah and
this this is this is basically um
uh a christmas carol yeah exactly so he
goes through the yeah yeah
he's scrooged yeah and and uh i was
thinking how can i do a second series
and uh tom basden who plays
matt in it um said yeah that's
interesting he said because some
you know christmas carolines and that's
it but what happens on boxing day
yeah season two is boxing day does he
keep it up
does he keep up what he's learned he's
no because most people don't
that's the problem though isn't is it
some some people don't want to watch a
guy who can't keep his promises when
they feel good because then they feel
that that's
human yeah because we keep promises and
we go back on it
you know um there's a lot more room with
this character i feel like
than some of the other ones there is and
there's not more room with it because we
have an explorer
i don't think i i don't think there's a
scene in afterlife that
tone is not in somewhere whereas now i
can go
we can go elsewhere we can we can you
know and that was hard to plot it as
well with so much stuff
um but now you can now you want to see
the other characters as well so you've
learned about them and uh
the second season of summer is always
the best and you and you used um the two
uh women that you'd worked with before
previously as the love interest
obviously
the wife and lots actually um ashley
jensen
is back as the nurse um
she's amazing she's brilliant um uh
carrie godleman plays my
my dead wife see if it was a sitcom
that's what it'd be called
yeah well it's a bit better than when
the whistle blows
it would have been crazy if you could
have slipped in uh
any of your catchphrases throughout the
time that would have been amazing yeah
yeah joe hartley's back um who's the um
who's your uh therapist because he's a
very famous paul kaye
yeah he's really amazing yeah i like
your interactions with him
it's great it was a bit like darren lam
type
yeah some of the things the way he said
it he made me laugh and i go let's go
again let's go again
like the first story he tells right that
that way lean forward like that i [__]
that
that gets me every time there's things
there's trigger things for me
um if it's meant to be funny don't make
me laugh if it's not meant to be funny
they can make me laugh
yes someone turning around in a drama
right you're me
if someone goes yeah i'm done i'm done
yeah you turned round
yeah if you appear from something if
someone this cannot be
this can never be not funny someone
looking around that can never be
so if you ever ever have to do that
seriously if i see a spy thing or
someone looking at a circle
if i see them do i go for a [__] don't
do that yeah let's cut that
let's
yeah so that makes me laugh um anything
so this method acting thing of being
lost in the moment no
everything makes me laugh i'm aware of
everything and everything's funny
and the and the less it's meant to be
funny
and the later and the more the boom ups
getting annoyed
the funnier it is what was the show that
made you laugh the most off
um when you weren't shooting the sort of
thing when you had the best laughs
uh oh my god um
i it just i think that they've all
pretty much been the same
officex was derek this one probably less
because it was more of a drama so
it was more procedural there was more
work to do like with
you know in the office i could come out
all the time everyone's at their desk
you know
extras i could [__] around all the time
because um uh
it it was funny it was meant to be funny
all the time so you know
uh derek again one room people saying
stupid things more ad lib
in derek than the other two so so if
people could catch me out like [__]
david earl
i'd live in one scene we didn't get
through the scene in the caravan
i just wouldn't forget it just him
and once once thing and i do it the same
i used to hand it out and i can't take
it so
once he knows he's got me i'm finished
there's no
there's nothing more joyous than not
being able to stop laughing there is
nothing more joyous in life than you're
going
i can't i'm in pain i'm in pain
right that that's the greatest feeling
in the [__] world
if you can't stop laughing right and
sometimes the yeah is a tip as well
the only the only antidote to the
funniest thing in the world
is someone saying the second funniest
thing in the world you know
a group of mates and they're laughing
about summer and then someone who's not
and they go
yeah and remember that they go yeah oh
cheers frank okay cheers that stopped us
in is not quite as funny yeah but that's
what i love to watch from the outside is
that person is saying that
and i love i i don't know why but
because of awkward things like the
office
i almost made it my mission sometimes to
say the second funniest thing well i
that's so funny to say that because in a
social situation i
i love i love awkward excruciatingly
yeah
but not in real life when it's not me if
someone if if i'm
if i'm at a social occasion i never was
laughing and someone makes a crap joke
and no one laughs i want to go i want to
go back in time
and save them oh
to try and just look at me don't look at
them i can't stand someone else being
um embarrassed but you can't i don't
care i'm not embarrassed
um if if someone if someone goes to the
loo and they come back and they've got a
patch of wee on their trousers right
and everyone knows and then someone says
you've got a patch a wee and they go red
i go [__] get me out of here because if
i come out i go [__] piss myself
again it's done
yeah it's done but being embarrassed
acknowledging you're embarrassed is
worse than being embarrassed i just
oh it's just how did you become so
self-comfortable like
just be like teflon because because
we're all going to die
we're all going to die imagine on your
deathbed you've got any regrets to go
yeah
i had a little bit of wee on the
trousers once
you're like people can't do that i can
do that
it's funny it's funny someone taking the
piss is funny
right honestly i grew up where it was
it was [__] it was like honestly
um last man standing everyone you can't
walk into the room
people would check make sure there was
nothing wrong with that like a label or
their hair or i used to have my mum cut
my hair
over a week because i didn't what i
couldn't go to school
haircut [__] i'm not giving them that
now i love it
now i leave stuff because i want i want
them to have a go you've got to give
people something
you've got to give some something we're
all idiots
and what my job is to let people know it
doesn't matter
we're all [__] idiots and that's
great there's no one but it doesn't give
you shouldn't give a [__] see i think
it's society's changing now because of
like instagram in that way
being able to laugh at yourself it
people seem to be getting worse at that
not not better because yeah because
you're enjoying their image because
image is now becoming
the actual thing yeah so before it was
that's who i am
and then there's image yeah now it's
image is just everything though yeah so
when you criticize people which really
do a lot it
they're not taking this it's yeah
someone having a go at your
instagram thing that you've worked hard
to create this fight they've
photoshopped that they took
all day or not yeah i mean it's your
week and be like that's bollocks
it really is they can't have it it's
yeah yeah again
it's it's like i talk about it's all
about wigs in humanity it's an odd
it's an odd lie it's an odd guy because
it
you've got a wig all night no one no i
don't
you know they're probably better now you
could have a wig for all i care but but
i don't it's all real but when i was
growing we rubbed the balloon
but someone walking in with a wig it was
it was
a wig mate yeah the wig mate in it
there's no no it's not it is you know
it's like it's just i like when you
convince the whole family to get it but
it's the pressure of every
the pressure of wearing a wig i'll go
you know the door goes you've got to put
that [__] wiggle yeah before you go
[__] you now i'm bald right i'm bored
just accept it and move on
yeah there's something really british
about that though that british people
cannot see something and like have that
there's that element of embarrassment
hair replacement therapy the sales of
that are going to be way low in
england america americans are quite
comfortable i suppose it's different
because
i don't think there's anyone with being
bald whereas if
if there was maybe i i don't know i
can't give an example of someone that
you hide
that you're embarrassed i i don't know
um i'm comfortable because
you should be comfortable right i i uh
um i i stopped being vain in that sense
and we're all vain we want to we want we
want people to
give us props for good things we've done
and uh we don't want to be the butt of
jokes and we don't want to you know we
everyone's got that sort of vanity and
you sort of demand respect and
and that's cool um but i stopped
worrying about things that when i was
about 28 29 i just thought i don't want
to stand up in a pub in
in tight trousers and just because that
sounds really bad i wasn't just
going to pubs in tight trousers for any
reason
i just i want comfort i want [__]
comfort i judge all my clothes
on comfort clearly yeah
i do and you know what it's obvious it's
not it's not if it would go
no rick you're you you're quite a you're
still trending like a snazzy dress at
you exactly yeah
you [__] fooled me do you think that
stops people from
imagine if i got offended and would that
blow your mind if i went
okay there's no need for that i think
i'm dealing with people so often now
it's going the other way
so i think it's changed now i don't know
why people think they have the right
to never have anything bad about more
teased or i don't know where they got
that from
i think they certainly didn't [__]
grow up in my family or
counselors day or school people who
think they have the right to never have
someone go
[__] it now you look like [__] yeah i
think
my mom might i went to college right i
came home from college once
and my mum went oh rick you and i've
getting fat and then fed me cake
you know it's like i was taught i was
brought up with honesty
i was brought up with honesty and it is
the best policy
it makes you bulletproof this this thing
now of
having safe spaces they must never hear
anything they don't agree with
you know someone said a phrase um
you shouldn't pave the jungle you
shouldn't pave the jungle
okay get out there and [__] learn how
to survive
don't [__] don't shut down everything
you don't want to hear
but what's the point of that you know
just [__] living
in a video game you've got you've got
out there
and experience it you should you should
you should
argue you should this thing about um
uh people i shouldn't hear
people say terrible things about you you
you should
and you know is the good bit you get to
say them back
you get to say them back people offended
by a joke
[__] hell jesus christ there are real
things in the world you should be
offended you're more offended
i once tweeted people are more offended
by jokes about war
famine in murder than actual warfare
they're not doing anything towards those
they
shouldn't joke about it what are you
doing towards the real thing you know
it's it's crazy
no it's it's mad yeah you can't i
uh i think that is that's down partly
down to the control that people have
though on those like that's partly down
to that instagram control of your image
and those sorts of things is
you feel like you have control over what
you see what you do and yeah you can
sort of shield yourself off from those
things yeah so when you invasively go
i don't know god isn't real or whatever
i didn't want that on the timeline
but that's what they're saying because
they think it's like i've gone to their
house
yeah exactly they've come to my house
they're following me
they've they've come to my house and sat
down and i've said to them and they're
going to [__] know what you're doing
mate i go well you're in my house mate
yeah you know
you can block me you don't have fake
outrage
of course there is just for the sake of
being outraged yeah and and again that
was something
that didn't exist before twitter that
someone would say something to me nasty
and i go i'd uh go back to them either
go what's there for me or
slam and i go oh man you replied i'm a
huge fan
and i looked at the timeline and they've
said 25 nice things but i haven't
noticed them so then they've gone to the
dart i'll go
mate why why would you rather me think
you're a [__] than not know about you
why is f why is being famous for being
[__]
better than not being famous i don't get
it
because everyone wants to go i was here
everyone
you know caveman blowing word on that i
was here
and now twitter everyone can say i was
here it
is it is reading every public toilet war
in the world
we're wrapping up now are we okay all
right okay couple more questions go on
i need a wii as well all right one
question just going uh
i've been in afterlife yeah the turning
point for him
it seems is his wife's death uh that
seems to be a huge like defining moment
and it's like
in your life if that was a movie what
would your turning point be what would
be the main
if there was a that actually existed
that was real
if you want to script it if you were to
write the movie of yours
what would be that oh
well uh
yeah bob coming in saying why do you
believe in god is
i think well my um my uh english teacher
saying right about what you know
um uh if
you don't count the bad you know the big
things you know
parents dying and uh the fact that we
always had pets
uh things like that are really
the fact that i had older brothers and
sisters and uh
when they moved out i got all their
bobbed dylan and neil young and
you know what i mean so all those all
those things they have a profound
and lasting and a really important
uh effect on your life but uh
i suppose what would the turning point
be um
it depends on what i do my life's and up
till when
but up to an adult um which probably
ended with me
uh wanting to be a pop star and failing
it would have been sitting at home
uh a working-class kid on the floor
watching mark bowen one tea time
and david bowie came on singing heroes
and i thought
[__] me who is that that's
that's who i want to be i like that that
would be it
the last question which i always ask
to everyone and it was just going to be
a horrible one
weirdly i've always wanted to ask you it
because it was inspired by
your series how would you like to be
remembered
i've asked us to robbie williams i've
asked this to a lot of people
the other terrible thing is i can't i
can't better that quote
i can't i cannot better it because it's
me isn't it it is
i'd love to i'd love i i'd [__]
love that simply i really would i really
genuine
as the man who put a smile on the face
of all who he met but that's not a bad
one yeah that's not a bad one i like it
yeah he yeah basically saying
he had a laugh he had a laugh and then
he found a lump
well i've thoroughly enjoyed it that was
great that was brilliant just sizing
i'll take your weightlifting something
when you're in london is that a bit of
training
you do do you uh do would you try it you
don't need a bodybuilder
no just like weightlifting and stuff
like that right oh so it's
a sport you do actually do a bit of
everything
yes will you um i do all the heavy
lifting on this podcast he's the
nice one yeah i remember once i had i um
eddie hall oh i [__] love
we've had him on the podcast he's great
right yeah but i had a routine i never
did it
right um he was an interviewer you know
he did the the first one to do
you half a ton yeah [__] nosebleed
half a [__] time
and he was really sweet and he was so
proud of it and i was i was
[__] like genuinely right over it and
uh he said uh
um he said something like uh
you know it's i really it's it's it's
why
i was put here right and i i had a
routine to go
so he's thinking that god put him there
right and then uh
and these for years he'd be going why am
i here
god says to lift stuff yeah what sort of
stuff really heavy stuff
yeah then what put it back down yeah
yeah it's like the dog thing on humanity
all right